hey there and welcome to Google cloud
next on air today we'll be talking about
how public data can help data scientists
researchers public health agencies and
others combat the novel 2019 coronavirus
also known as Kovan 19 and help flatten
the curve of cases around the globe
my name is Shane glass I'm a developer
advocate here at Google cloud covering
business intelligence and I'm also the
tech lead for the cloud public data sets
program I'm thankful to be joined today
by my co-presenter Xavier Xavier you
want to take a minute to introduce
yourself sure hi everybody my name is
Xavier and I'm the co-founder of corto
awesome thanks Xavier so here's a quick
outline of what we intend to cover today
so start with a quick overview of Google
clouds public data sets program we
currently offer more than 180 public
machine learning ready data sets
available in our products both is
structured data sets in our server list
data warehouse bigquery and unstructured
data sets like satellite imagery in
Google Cloud storage and we work hard to
ensure that each of these data sets are
as up-to-date as possible according to
the requirements of each individual data
set sometimes this means real-time
updates like our cryptocurrency
blockchains
and sometimes this means annual updates
like US Census Bureau boundaries we're
also working with our partners team
members and customers to identify new
data sets of interest that could expand
our catalog as well so ultimately what
does this mean for you there's no need
to worry about ETL for some of the most
high-value public data sets in the world
we preload these core data sets and
makes life easier for the data analyst
and data scientist by reducing time to
get started and helping you unlock new
insights in your existing data now it's
the köppen 19 pandemic truly began to
spread across the globe we recognize the
need for expanded access to analyze data
the documents the spread of the virus
and its impacts in March of 2020 we
announced our Cova 19 public data sets
program
which now contains more than 20 data
sets to make it as easy as possible for
researchers and data scientists to
combat Cove in nineteen DS data sets are
pre-loaded into bigquery and continually
updated to reduce the time to analyze
the data in addition to the free access
we up provide for all public data sets
queries against Cova nineteen public
data sets are provided at no cost
through September 15 to maximize the
ability for researchers to fight covin
19 these includes datasets detailing
kovat 19 confirmed cases and deaths
around the world like those available
from the New York Times the Italian
Department of Civil Protection and the
European Centre for disease and
prevention and control data sets that
contain information about how
governments are acting to combat covin
19 such as the Oxford kovat 19
government response tracker that
describes policy actions that have been
put into place to mitigate the impacts
of kovat 19 and datasets that can
contextualize outbreaks such as the US
Census Bureau's American Community
Survey we think this can truly make a
difference in flattening the curve let's
pause here for a second for those
unfamiliar with bigquery bigquery is
Google clouds highly scalable enterprise
data warehouse solution it's a fully
managed in surplice offers real-time
insights from streaming data has built
in ml out of the box and as a high speed
in memory bi engine for faster and
reporting and analysis bigquery is
designed to make data analyst and data
scientists more productive and it's a
secure offering that offers data
encryption by default both in transit
and at rest to ensure that your data are
protected okay
so let's get back to the public data
combat Cove in 19 now we believe that
the Cova 19 public data sets we are
hosting combined with the high powered
analysis platforms like bigquery and
Cardo can help support the mitigation of
the impact of kovat 19 in three primary
ways the first of these is informing
individual decision making and in my
opinion this might be the most important
this is critical to slowing the spread
of the virus by helping individuals
understand the importance of social
distancing the importance of wearing a
mask and other safeguards it can also
help researchers and public health
officials better understand which policy
actions are having a positive impact now
the second of these use cases is
analyzing the second order public health
impacts of the pandemic secondary public
health impacts of the virus include
potential food insecurity among
employees and industries that are most
likely be displaced by the kovat 19
impact on the economy according to the
public health officials we've worked
with these datasets are typically used
by public health officials to identify
people and regions that are dealing with
impacts of the pandemic other than the
virus itself data sets such as Google's
community mobility reports the Census
Bureau's American Community Survey and
global health and population trends from
the World Bank are crucial to help
Public Health officials better
understand and ensure that the full
public health impact of the pandemic is
mitigated and finally we're helping
inform individual economic
decision-making such as helping
governments make an informed data-driven
decision about reopening economies
combining these datasets such as data
about us
khoka 19 cases from USA facts the oxford
university government policy response
tracker a created hospital capacity from
the American Hospital Association and
geotubes commercial mobility impacts
government officials and businesses can
make an informed decision about the
risks and benefits of reopening their
economies
this can help states such as the five
Western states that make up the western
states pact take a data-driven approach
to measuring their published criteria
for reopening economies including the
ability of hospitals to handle a new
wave of patients and protect those most
vulnerable to Cova 19 so let's take a
look at some examples of how Google
clouds customers are already seeing
success using Cova 19 public data sets
in the three categories we've laid out
the first of these is the state of
Oklahoma state officials in Oklahoma
collaborated with teams from across
Google cloud to develop and launch a
looker dashboard that helped keep their
citizens informed of the current status
this helps reinforce the importance of
Public Health efforts by providing
citizens transparency into the
decision-making process in the impacts
of these decisions the second of these
is analyzing the second order public
health impacts of the pandemic decart
Labs has built and widely published an
analysis that shows the reduction of
pollution and other emissions within
areas that have high number of kovat 19
cases in that are currently under stay
at home or safer at home orders and the
final example is from the emergent
Alliance a data analytics coalition that
spearheaded by rolls-royce the emergent
alliance is a response from a growing
number of global brains who believe in
using the power of big data for the
greater good by combining private and
public datasets the emergent alliance
aims to accelerate and smooth economic
recovery from the Cova 19 crisis their
stated mission is to help governments
businesses and communities help each
other in the recovery and provide better
insights through better data that
provide better outcomes for everybody
now a lot of this amazing work is only
possible because of the powerful
analytics platforms that are available
now one of these is Cardone a leading
spatial analytics company headquartered
in New York City I'm joined today all
the way from Madrid Spain by their
founder and chief strategy officer
Javier de la Torre to talk a little more
about how they are helping their
customers leverage public data to combat
ghovat 19 have you thanks sang I'm
pretty excited to be here today
collaborating with Google on community
mediation we have seen an explosion on
usage of maps and location intelligence
to FICO 19 it's like the entire
population had cut almost a 101 course
on maps and mobility recently and that's
because I like to say there's there have
been a more important time to geography
understanding the geography of the Panda
and the mobility of the population is
one of the few tools that we have right
now available to find could be a Carter
we have been pretty busy over the last
months at the beginning of the pandemic
working with different governments and
organizations and the response to it and
big query has been a fundamental part
you know to handle very large spatial
datasets on these use cases but before
so we do that it's not so I really you
know give you a little quick intro about
Carter also cartridge allocation
Intelligence Platform will help
organizations analyze can visualize
location data let me tell you a little
bit about what it means one way that I
like to explain what location is
location intelligence is is by
explaining the difference between
understanding word and understanding why
you want to look at word there's more
copied 19 cases you will likely use a bi
tool such as looker but if you want to
understand why there are more cases on
one place versus another if you want to
understand you're right what are the
characteristics of those places that
makes them more vulnerable to a copy
then you need to create what we call a
spatial model and for doing that you
need card so we Carter think about
you're creating a spatial models that
help you understand why something
happens so now we provide these
capabilities in a product with different
interfaces we work with data scientists
analysts and developers and more
important thing very relevant in this
case Carter would like to say comes also
with batteries included most of our
users use Carter with data Observatory
which is our repository of a spatial
data things like demographics mobility
financial data that is useful for doing
a lot of these analysis a lot of these
data sets will be collaborating with the
bigquery public datasets you know to to
make them available to the bigquery
community now more widely Carter and
Google cloud platform provides a full
solution of what we call and next
generation spatial data infrastructure
with composers like the AI platform and
bigquery
Google cloud platform together with
Carter
provides a great new way of thinking
about the spatial analysis and we have
been liberated we said a lot during
committee 19 so let me show you a few
use cases so the first one as we were
describing combining location data could
be 19 cases government can actually
create what we call risk models you can
do risk analysis to understand which
areas are more vulnerable depending on
things like demographics like 8 you know
to have a bigger effect commit 19 right
so these type of analysis are possible
by conveying combining a lot of the
datasets that song saying you were
talking before now another use case that
I like a lot and you put it you know I
refer very well there's been an
incredible pressure on governments to
explain the reasons why wait why they
are closing up on open app you know like
those lock downs have been affecting so
many people and in order to do that they
had to be very responsible in the way
they publicize you know the data and how
they explain the stories behind it so
helping you know to tell those stories
and make turns to get transparency today
that makes it way more effective and you
mix it you know like citizens
understands the importance of those
measurements of course another typical
color use case that would be the same is
associating human mobility we changes on
the economy we now you know when
lockdowns happens you know like the
economy shrinks so trying to understand
the correlation between between these
two factors and it's a pretty important
factor and can help you to collect
understand and mitigate the economic
impact of kabhi 19 the next one it's it
and you're like a more practical things
you know like this situation has made us
well I have to kind of deal about like
how many people come with it on a beach
you know while maintaining secure
distance right so all those type of
analysis also require a lot of light
data transition and data analytics we
see that particular like in in cases you
know where we work with governments on
understanding the
for tens of the lockdowns but also we
seen quite a lot on the private sector
so understanding the impact of a
particular for a particular retailer of
those lockdowns
and the different countries where
they're operating so those are also a
very classical cases where you're mixing
data that you have on the public data
sets together with your own enterprise
data in this case to see how kuwait 19
is affecting your business lastly I
think also something that we've seen and
we've been working a lot is
understanding and I'm preparing working
on data around mobility inside offices
as you know more businesses are opening
up and like we hear more and more you
know the need for understanding like
mobility in doors right so if you track
movements of employees while at the
office you can obtain reports like who's
been encounter with whom like within
three meters so in the same room which
parts of the office produce more
contacts how can you adapt time tables
to reduce those contacts well as you can
see there's many use cases where you can
apply spatial analytics together with a
spatial data like the one that is
available on the bigquery public
datasets not to to fight on copy 19 so
what do you think saying I think it's a
great idea why don't we look at some
demos I'll go first all I'll show a
couple queries in bigquery and we can
come back to you and then show how we
can visualize those sounds great okay
now let's take a look at some examples
of how Cova 19 data can be helped use to
flatten the curve we'll start here by
looking at Kovan 19 cases by county
across the US and joining demographic
data from the Census Bureau's American
Community Survey the demo that we're
looking at here gives us cases and
deaths by US county and also a litany of
different demographic factors including
total population population density
income age gender and race this data can
be used to help contextualize an
outbreak and better understand some
potential factors that are in play we
can also use it
to create a dashboard and looker the
newest member of Google clouds family
for business intelligence this allows us
to visualize data drill down by county
or state and provide contextual
visualizations around it now let's take
a look at our next demo which is Kovan
19 cases normalized by county population
in this case per 100,000 now we can
quickly run this query as well and we'll
get a result for the number of cases
within the last day by us county but now
xavier what if we wanted to visualize a
query like this could you show us what
that would look like
the query is known for handling large
amounts of data so we saw rising large
amounts of data it sounds something that
pretty much snippet so for example this
data set from New York City and the taxi
trips that this available on big
bigquery public data that's around 131
million GPS points we have found a way
to visualize this and here is a demo of
that this is your hundred thirty-one
million points visualize them up and as
you can see as i zoom in you can see how
you know the maps gets loaded
progressively until if I soon enough
each of these points represents one of
the records on that table and this is
possible because we process the data
into what we call tile sets we've been
working over the last few months to to
generate this tacit starting from
bigquery and we have a solution for it
so you can see now we can progress not
hundreds of meaning we can progress
process billions of records in very very
effectively using bigquery
so using this tile set generation die
only from a query without moving the
data out of it you can get like data
sets like this one 300 million builders
did you ask all the buildings in the
United States and directly so from
within bigquery so if you're interesting
to use this type of technology for tasks
a generation will have an open beta
program and you can get access by
sending us an email to bigquery at carto
well then this will be pre relevant to
people who are working with very large
spatial data sets
that's awesome Xavier thanks for the
demo I personally can't wait to use
Cardo to dig in a little deeper to
figure out why things are happening
where they're happening okay well that's
all for us here today at Google cloud
next on air if you'd like to learn more
about how you can use public data it's a
combat Cove in nineteen out the
following resources you can check out
more specific examples of how data
science in public data can support
public health efforts to fight Cove in
nineteen by watching our cloud on-air
webinar from May
titled data science for Public Health
working with public
nineteen datasets you can also check out
the full catalog of public datasets
available on google cloud by visiting
the google cloud marketplace using the
short link on the right additionally
there are a number of other cloud next
on-air sessions talking about how Google
cloud is helping support the response to
kovat 19 there's so many to choose from
from the industrial insight session on
planning for retails new priorities
hosted by our VP of retail Carrie Tharp
to the breakout session data-driven
responses to Kovan 19 using looker and
bigquery hosted by my friend and
colleague Lea Jarrett who runs the
product demonstration for looker in
particular I recommend checking out a
Shama Gupta's talk on reimagining
healthcare in Cova 19 era and Mike
Daniels the session on reimagining the
public sector in the Cova 19 era both of
these talks do a really great job of
expanding on the concepts we covered
today that's all for us and thanks for
watching Google cloud next on air